This is 99% Invisible. I'm Swan Royale. Every year around this time in New York City, when the weather starts getting colder and the world starts to slow down a bit, I think about the summer that slipped away, and I always have the same thought, God, I wish I had gone to the beach more. And not just any beach, but this one beach in particular. The People's Beach at Jacob Rees Park, also known simply as Rees. My first time at Rees was July 4th, 2017. This is artist, producer, and dear friend, Jasmine JT Green. I was seven months into living in Brooklyn after a move from Chicago.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是 Swan Royale。每年这个时候，在纽约市，当天气开始变冷，世界开始慢下来时，我就会想起那个悄然溜走的夏天，我脑海里总是浮现出同一个想法：天哪，我真希望当时能多去几次海滩。而且不是随便哪个海滩，而是特指这片海滩。雅各布·里斯公园的人民海滩，通常也被简称为里斯海滩。我第一次去里斯海滩是在 2017 年 7 月 4 日。这位是艺术家、制作人兼挚友，Jasmine JT Green。当时我从芝加哥搬到布鲁克林才七个月。
The ocean was never part of my landlocked life in the Midwest, but after a crew of new friends invited me to a group chat titled Beach with two sun emojis, I knew that my Lake Michigan kiss toes would soon touch the Atlantic. When I first got to Rees, it first appeared to be a larger version of my Midwestern beach past. A cute bazaar of food, sunburnt shoulders, and that summer's generic Drake song playing from many a speaker. But as I wondered where the six of us would land for our afternoon of escapism, everyone except myself seemed to already know where to head.
在大西部内陆的生活中，海洋从未成为我生命的一部分。但当一群新朋友邀请我加入一个群聊，群名是带着两个太阳表情符号的“海滩”时，我知道我那曾亲吻密歇根湖的脚趾很快就要触碰大西洋了。当我第一次到达里斯海滩时，它最初看起来像是我的中西部海滩过去的放大版。一个可爱的小吃集市、晒伤的肩膀，还有许多扬声器里播放着那个夏天千篇一律的德雷克（Drake）歌曲。但正当我琢磨着我们六个人该把落脚点选在哪里，来度过这个逃离现实的下午时，除了我之外，似乎所有人都已经知道该往哪里走了。
We were walking to the eastern edge of the beach, 20 minutes from the parking lot, past the playgrounds and food carts and public bathrooms. Eventually, we landed on a patch of sand that was partially shaded by an abandoned building, separate from the beach by a metal fence. For decades, this large, graffiti-covered structure loomed behind this sliver of Reeves Beach. It formed a kind of U-shape facing the shore. This abandoned building was called the Nipponset Beach Hospital.
我们正走向海滩的东边缘，距离停车场有 20 分钟的路程，走过了游乐场、餐车和公共厕所。最终，我们来到了一片沙滩上，这里部分被一座废弃的建筑遮阴，建筑与海滩之间隔着一道金属栅栏。几十年来，这座布满涂鸦的大型建筑一直隐现在里斯海滩这小片沙滩的后方。它形成了一种朝向海岸的U形。这座废弃的建筑被称为尼庞西特海滩医院（Neponsit Beach Hospital）。
The area right in front of it is where queer folks have chosen to call their home. This rundown old hospital became a landmark of queer sanctuary. It offered a kind of protective shadow for this queer paradise to persist. Jasmine Green is going to take the story of queer Reese from here. Ever since that first visit to Reese, I've made a trip every summer to enjoy a nutcracker while gazing at the Atlantic Ocean. But while Reeves is known for topless bathing and running into your exes, it was never intended to be a queer public space, and its identity shifted and morphed into many things before we called it
正对着它的这片区域，是酷儿群体选择称之为家的地方。这座破旧的老医院成为了酷儿庇护所的地标。它为这片酷儿乐园的延续提供了一种保护性的阴凉。Jasmine Green 将从这里接手讲述酷儿里斯的故事。自从第一次访问里斯以来，我每年夏天都会去一次，一边啜饮着胡桃夹子鸡尾酒，一边凝视着大西洋。虽然里斯以无上装日光浴和偶遇前任而闻名，但它从来都不是为了成为酷儿公共空间而建造的，在被称为
our home. Last year, after decades of abandonment, the city's health department demolished Niponset Beach Hospital. And the demolition brought with it a new set of questions. How did queer Reeves come to be? What might become of it now? It's so striking how it like, going to the beach used to be, you'd see this huge building and you'd, and it was this like,oming, abandoned structure. It's in the background of all of the photos I have of Reese. And it's completely gone now.
我们的家之前，它的身份历经了多次转变和重塑。去年，在荒废了数十年之后，市卫生部门拆除了尼庞西特海滩医院。而拆除工作也带来了新的一系列问题。酷儿里斯是如何诞生的？它现在又会变成什么样？最惊人的是，就像，过去去海滩时，你会看到这座巨大的建筑，而且它是一个像这样，阴森森的、废弃的结构。它出现在我所有关于里斯的照片的背景中。而现在它已经完全消失了。
This is Dean Labowitz. I'm Dean Labowitz. I'm an urban planner and researcher and writer and person who loves and adores Reese above all else, yeah. Rees is Dean's queer haven as well. Their apartment is decorated with shells and sea glass they've collected from the beach. I always celebrate my birthday at Rees
这是 Dean Labowitz。我是 Dean Labowitz。我是一名城市规划师、研究员、作家，也是一个无比热爱里斯的人，对，没错。里斯也是迪恩的酷儿避风港。他们的公寓里装饰着从海滩上收集的贝壳和海玻璃。我总是在里斯庆祝我的生日
because I have a late June birthday. And as I like to say, God's gay children were born on the days around pride. Dean filled me in on the history of Rees. In 1914, before it was a beach, it was a military base for the Rockaway Naval Air Station. And then in 1915, the Niponsant Beach Hospital, our beloved four-story red brick abandoned behemoth was built. There were beautiful porches, open-air balconies, and eastern and western wing openings all
因为我的生日在六月下旬。正如我喜欢说的，上帝的同性恋孩子都是在自豪日周边的日子出生的。Dean 向我介绍了里斯的历史。1914 年，在它成为海滩之前，这里是洛卡威海军航空站的军事基地。然后在 1915 年，尼庞西特海滩医院——我们心爱的四层红砖废弃庞然大物——建成了。这里有漂亮的门廊、露天阳台，东西两侧的翼楼开口都
facing the beach. The hospital was intended to treat children with tuberculosis. Soon after World War I, the military abandoned its base and the city decided to create a public park there instead, Jacob Reeves Park. Jacob Reeves was a social reformer and photojournalist who advocated for building parks, playgrounds and houses for the poor and working class. With bath houses and picnic tables, the goal of Reeves was to provide public transit accessible recreation for New York's working class. And then in the 1930s, the whole thing was scrapped and redesigned by Robert Moses.
面向海滩。这家医院原本是为了治疗患有结核病的儿童。第一次世界大战后不久，军方废弃了该基地，市政府决定在那里改建一个公共公园，即雅各布·里斯公园。雅各布·里斯（Jacob Riis）是一位社会改革家和摄影记者，他倡导为穷人和工人阶级建设公园、游乐场和住宅。随着浴室和野餐桌的建立，里斯的目标是为纽约工人阶级提供公共交通便利的休闲场所。然后在 20 世纪 30 年代，这一切都被废弃，并由罗伯特·摩西（Robert Moses）重新设计。
That Robert Moses led redesign was classic Robert Moses. It was this huge 14,000 car parking lot, gigantic. I think somebody said it was like one of the largest in the U.S. at some point. And while the property was taken up mostly by the parking lot, the beach got an expansion while the rest of the park, like the bath house, got a facelift. There was even a golf course built, but the hospital stayed put, untouched. I believe initially, like you couldn't access the beachfront in front of the hospital because it was a working hospital.
罗伯特·摩西主导的那次重新设计非常具有罗伯特·摩西的风格。这是一个巨大的、拥有 14,000 个停车位的停车场，规模极其庞大。我想有人曾说过它在某个时期是美国最大的停车场之一。虽然这处地产大部分被停车场占据，但海滩得到了扩建，而公园的其他部分，比如浴室，则焕然一新。甚至还修建了一个高尔夫球场，但医院却原地不动，完好无损。我最初认为，比如你无法进入医院正前方的海滩，因为它是一家仍在运营的医院。
But even then, it was like, basically as soon as it opened, it was a queer beach. This was the 1940s, and ever since, queer people have been flocking to this part of the beach in front of the hospital. Yeah, we are looking at, it's a little bit of a crop of a larger picture. This is documentary artist Chris Bernsen. After combing through his own photos, he showed me some archives he started collecting of queer life throughout the decades, including this one by photographer Frank Hallam. In this series of pictures we're seeing, there's a lot of naked guys and you can tell
但即便如此，它就像是，基本上刚一开放，它就是一个酷儿海滩。这是 20 世纪 40 年代，自那以后，酷儿们就一直蜂拥至医院前方的这片海滩。对，我们正在看的是，一张更大照片的局部裁剪。这是纪录片艺术家 Chris Bernsen。在翻阅了自己的照片后，他给我展示了一些他开始收集的几十年来酷儿生活的档案，其中包括摄影师 Frank Hallam 的这张照片。在我们看到的这一系列照片中，有很多裸体男人，你能看出
he's clearly just trying to take a picture of like a naked guy without asking his permission. And so he just kind of passes through but okay, so now we're looking at a picture of Nippon's at hospital in the early 80s and it is just looking so glorious like no broken windows no graffiti. There still is the fence line. And you can see there's just queers all up and down the area. And in the foreground, you're seeing just a lot of people. Some are naked, some are not, just hanging out.
他显然只是在试图拍一张裸男的照片，而没有征得对方的同意。所以他只是路过，好吧，现在我们看到的是 20 世纪 80 年代初的尼庞西特海滩医院的照片，它看起来是如此辉煌，没有破碎的窗户，没有涂鸦。栅栏线依然存在。你可以看到整个区域到处都是酷儿。在前景中，你会看到很多人。有些是裸体的，有些则没有，只是在闲逛。
Everyone's fashion is really on point. Reeves Beach, in its entirety, is fairly large. 260 acres, to be exact, but it's only here in front of this hospital that queer folks claimed as their own. The nature of this building, mostly housing tuberculosis patients, led to it being an undesired site in the neighborhood, and the building offered a physical shield that made it the perfect place for uninterrupted debauchery. Chris kept flipping through these photos until he came across one of my now favorites by
每个人的时尚感都很到位。里斯海滩整体相当大。确切地说有 260 英亩，但只有在这里——这家医院的前方，才是酷儿们认领为自己的地方。这座建筑的性质，主要容纳肺结核患者，导致它成为该社区不受欢迎的场所，而这座建筑提供了一个物理屏障，使其成为不受打扰的纵欲狂欢的完美场所。Chris 继续翻看着这些照片，直到他看到了我现在的最爱之一——
Richard Peckinpah. It was a crowd of people, maybe 100 total. It's the 60s maybe? And in the foreground there's all sorts of people, like all sorts, not just cisgender white men. It looked very close to the Reeves I know and love today. You're seeing like a multiracial gathering of people. You're seeing women.
Richard Peckinpah 的作品。那是一群人，大约总共有 100 人。也许是 60 年代？在前景中有着各种各样的人，真的是各种各样，不仅仅是顺性别白人男性。这看起来非常接近我今天所熟知和热爱的里斯。你看到的是一个多元种族的聚人群体。你看到了女性。
Also, you're seeing these bathing suits that look like so hip today even, with like these little revealing sides. It's just like, to me, this is like this weird, timeless image where I'm like, Reeves has always been a congregation point for everybody. Stay in, stay in. Reeves, let's say, I'm like, Reese has always been a congregation point for everybody. Say it, say it! Reese!
此外，你还看到这些泳装，即使在今天看起来也非常时髦，带有这种微微暴露侧边的设计。这就像，对我来说，这是一个奇怪的、永恒的画面，让我想：里斯一直是一个适合所有人的聚集点。留下，留下！里斯，这么说吧，我就觉得：里斯一直是一个适合所有人的聚集点。说出来，说出来！里斯！
Let's say it together! Three, five, seven, nine. Lesbians are mighty fun. Yay! Yay! Woohoo! The body is more accepted here, and so people tend to think of people who show their body as exhibitionists.
让我们一起说！三，五，七，九。女同性恋者超级有趣。耶！耶！呜呼！这里对身体的接纳度更高，所以人们往往会把那些展示身体的人视为表现欲强的人。
And it's very common on this bay. And while this beach became a popular spot for cruising and reveling in the nude, the cops were also cruising for citations. This was kind of the cruisy spot of the beach. And so it was a place where you could cruise, but it's also a place where men were targeted for doing so by the police. And historically, one of the things that a lot of people were very scared of, at least in the 60s from interviews that I hear, is just, you know, if you got a ticket or got in trouble in this part of the beach. It was kind of without you a little bit. So if people that you weren't out to found out, they would assume you might be gay.
这在这片海湾非常普遍。虽然这片海滩成为了调情和裸体狂欢的热门地点，但警察也会来这里巡视并开具罚单。这里可以说是海滩上调情约会的聚集地。所以它是一个你可以调情的地方，但它也是一个男人们因为这样做而成为警察打击目标的地方。从历史上看，很多人非常害怕的一件事，至少根据我听到的 60 年代的采访来看，就是，你知道的，如果你在这片海滩拿到了罚单或惹上了麻烦。这就有点像变相出柜了。所以如果那些你尚未向其出柜的人知道了，他们就会认为你可能是同性恋。
Once we reached the 80s, the hospital was still operating in the background, though it was no longer specifically a children's hospital. There was a metal fence that separated the hospital from the beach, but Chris told me that beachgoers and hospital patients would pass cigarettes back and forth through the fence. There was a camaraderie and an exchange and actually like a porous relationship with the people that were in the hospital. I mean if you look at the history of this beach and of this
到了 20 世纪 80 年代，医院仍然在背景中运营，尽管它已不再专门作为儿童医院。有一道金属栅栏将医院与海滩隔开，但 Chris 告诉我，海滩游客和住院病人会隔着栅栏递香烟。有一种同志情谊、一种交流，实际上就像是与医院里的人建立了一种互通的关系。我的意思是，如果你看看这座海滩和这座
hospital, it's a really fascinating history to think about. This was built as a tuberculosis clinic and TB was like a very stigmatized illness when this was built in the 1930s. So there's this long history of us kind of being next to this space where people are kind of kept at a distance from the rest of society.
医院的历史，你会发现思考这段历史非常迷人。这里最初是作为一个肺结核诊所建造的，在 20 世纪 30 年代建造时，结核病是一种带有很大耻辱感的疾病。所以这里有着一段悠久的历史，我们紧挨着这样一个空间，而里面的人在某种程度上与社会的其余部分保持着一定的距离。
And that's how it was for the next several decades. Eventually the building transitioned from hospital to nursing home. And then in 1998, a stormy weekend swept through the Rockaways. It raced through central New York just after midnight on Labor Day morning and left a path of destruction unlike any storm we've seen before or since.
在接下来的几十年里，情况一直如此。最终，这座建筑从医院转型为疗养院。然后在 1998 年，一个暴风雨的周末席卷了洛卡威。它在劳动节早晨午夜刚过不久呼啸着穿过纽约中部，留下一片破坏的痕迹，这是我们之前或之后从未见过的一场风暴。
Thousands of trees were destroyed, changing the landscape. Here's Dean again. It was like estimated there was like half a million dollars in damage done, which is like not nothing, right? This was when Rudy Giuliani was the mayor and was very much the king of privatizing New York. This damage was the perfect excuse to shut down this publicly funded hospital. But he did it in the middle of the night.
成千上万棵树木被毁，改变了地貌。这是 Dean。据估计，造成的损失大约有五十万美元，这可不是小数目，对吧？当时鲁迪·朱利安尼（Rudy Giuliani）正担任市长，他非常热衷于将纽约私有化。这场破坏成了关闭这家由公众资助的医院的绝佳借口。但他是在半夜动手关闭的。
And there was something close to like 300 nursing home patients still in the building. Several died in the process of being evacuated in the middle of the night. in the process of being evacuated in the middle of the night. Renovations to the damaged building were promised to residents, but they never came, and the residents never returned. The hospital was closed soon after and stayed vacant for years. Decay began to set in as that red brick became a dusty brown. This was the reese I saw when I encountered it for the first time. A sandy beach adjacent to the hospital, further falling into disarray.
而且当时大楼里还有差不多 300 名疗养院的病人。其中好几人在半夜撤离的过程中不幸身亡。在半夜撤离的过程中不幸身亡。当局曾向居民承诺会对受损的建筑进行翻修，但承诺从未兑现，居民们也再也没有回来。不久后医院便关闭了，并空置多年。随着红砖变成暗淡的灰褐色，衰败的气息开始弥漫。这就是我第一次见到里斯时的样子。一片紧邻着医院的沙滩，正进一步陷入杂乱无章。
On one side, enlarged text, graffiti-red queer trans power. On the other side, know your power. Many a queer will make a sanctuary out of anything. Rees was no exception. With cracked windows and rusted metal, the hospital gave off a vibe that we weren't supposed to be there. And we were drawn to it. And I've noticed this elsewhere, too.
在一边，放大的文字，用红漆写着“酷儿跨性别力量”（QUEER TRANS POWER）。在另一边，“了解你的力量”（KNOW YOUR POWER）。许多酷儿能把任何东西变成庇护所。里斯也不例外。伴随着破碎的窗户和生锈的金属，这座医院散发着一种我们本不该在那里的氛围。而我们却被它吸引。我其他地方也注意到这一点。
Think about Chicago's Belmont Rocks, or Marshall's Beach underneath the Golden Gate Bridge, or the old Chelsea Piers on the New York waterfront. Queerness is scrappiness, creating a life and culture out of society's leftovers, and existing figuratively and literally in the margins. I think that queers thrive being kind of on that,
想想芝加哥的贝尔蒙特岩石（Belmont Rocks），或者金门大桥底下的马歇尔海滩（Marshall's Beach），又或是纽约海滨的老切尔西码头（Chelsea Piers）。酷儿气质就是一种拼搏坚韧，从社会的残羹冷炙中创造出生活与文化，并在边缘地带象征性地和字面意义上生存。我认为酷儿们在那种地方能够茁壮成长，
in that in-between place where it's less regulated and there's more possibilities. So like we are more likely to be left alone. As the Naponset Beach Hospital fell further apart, we kept sunbathing around it. A hospital that was continually serving marginalized groups felt to be the perfect fit for shielding the most vulnerable of New Yorkers.
在那种监管较少、拥有更多可能性的中间地带。所以我们更有可能不被外界打扰。随着尼庞西特海滩医院进一步破败，我们继续在它周围进行日光浴。一家不断为边缘化群体服务的医院，感觉非常适合为纽约最脆弱的群体提供庇护。
It actually was kind of a visual shield from the neighborhood next to it. So they didn't really see us as much because of that. So there was a certain amount of kind of like protection in that. But I think we also just like living in these places that have less rules and have more possibility for us to be and do what we want to do.
它实际上就像是来自邻近社区的一个视觉屏障。正因如此，他们其实没那么容易看到我们。所以这其中有一定的保护作用。但我认为我们也只是喜欢生活在这些规矩更少、对我们来说有更多可能去做我们想做的事的地方。
Over the next few decades, the property was stuck in a political and legal cold war. Proposals shuffled back and forth to renovate or not, to demolish or not. In the 2000s, it was estimated that millions of dollars were spent to maintain the hospital. We're talking about things like fences, guard houses, cleaning up debris. Until spring of 2023, when the hospital was finally torn down. When I first heard that the hospital was demolished, it took me by surprise. Here was this place that had been part of my experience for so long, completely vanished. And I was scared.
在接下来的几十年里，这处地产陷入了政治和法律的冷战。关于是否翻修、是否拆除的提案来回扯皮。在 20 世纪 2000 年代，据估计耗费了数百万美元来维护这家医院。我们谈论的是诸如围栏、警卫室、清理废墟之类的事情。直到 2023 年春天，这座医院终于被彻底拆除。当我第一次听说医院被拆除时，我感到非常震惊。这个融入了我生活经历这么久的地方，竟然彻底消失了。我很害怕。
I didn't know what would become of this place that had made me, and if these changes would no longer make me feel safe. And we all wondered what would happen to the future of queer Reeves now that our private oasis was no longer in shadow. Lately, arrests at Reeves for public nudity and other infractions have been rising. The Rockaway Times, the local papers at that slice of Queens, published a report featuring quotes from local residents,
我不知道这个塑造了我的地方将会变成什么样，也不知道这些改变是否会让我不再感到安全。我们都在纳闷，既然我们的私人绿洲不再有阴影庇护，酷儿里斯的未来将会如何。最近，里斯因公开裸露和其他违规行为而被捕的事件一直在增加。《洛卡威时报》（The Rockaway Times），这个皇后区那个角落的本地报纸，发表了一篇报道，其中引用了当地居民的话，
demanding an end to quote Ree of Queens, published a report featuring quotes from local residents, demanding an end to quote, Reeves porn, propping children's safety as their number one concern. The organization GLITS, Gays and Lesbians Living in a Transgender Society, has been working on a proposal, a community land trust that leads to a healthcare facility that focuses on trans New Yorkers. Because there aren't many public and fairly queer spaces that especially don't surround alcohol and expensive tickets, Reeves feels to be one of the few left. But like the history of the Chelsea Pierses queer past being erased into a playground
要求结束所谓的“皇后区的里斯事件”，并刊登了当地居民的引言，要求结束所谓的“里斯色情”（Rees porn），将儿童安全宣传为他们的头号关切。酷儿跨性别社群生活组织（GLITS，Gays and Lesbians Living in a Transgender Society）一直在致力于一项提案，即建立一个社区土地信托基金，用于打造一个专注于跨性别纽约人的医疗设施。由于没有多少公共且相当酷儿的空间，特别是那些不围绕酒精和昂贵门票的空间，里斯感觉是为数不多的几个幸存者之一。但就像切尔西码头的酷儿过去被抹去并变成富人游乐场的历史一样，
for the rich, its legacy is at risk of being washed away. Chris would hate to see that happen to Reece. Chris What I would really love to see there personally is like native plants and grasses and trees be planted there and like let's use that as a place to kind of a little bit rewild the space and give some some nature back to the place. Perhaps maybe in future images, there will be more cute butts, but in the background, just a little bit more trees.
它的遗产面临着被冲刷殆尽的风险。Chris 绝对不想看到里斯遭遇这样的命运。Chris 我个人非常希望看到那里能种植本土植物、草类和树木，并且我们可以把这里作为一个稍微让这片空间恢复野性、并将一些大自然还给这个地方的场所。也许在未来的照片里，会有更多可爱的屁股，但在背景里，能有更多的树木就好了。
A little more trees. I wish we had a little bit of a shade structure. I went to Reeves recently and it's so much different than what it used to be. Sure there's a brand new snack shop which is tasty, but without the hospital building, things feel so much more on display. I still felt comfortable, but more exposed. But that discomfort wasn't enough to scare me away. I was drawn to it that day, especially because it was the first time that I arrived to the beach as a trans woman.
再多一点树。我真希望我们能有一个遮阳的建筑结构。我最近去了里斯，它跟过去相比已经大不相同了。当然，现在有一个全新的小吃店，东西很好吃，但没有了医院大楼，一切都让人感觉更加暴露在众目睽睽之下。我仍然感到舒适，但更多的是暴露在外。但这种不适感还不足以吓退我。那天我被它深深吸引，尤其是因为那是我第一次以跨性别女性的身份来到海滩。
I brought my freshly prescribed hormones, and when 6pm hit, I would take my first dose, and I wanted to take it here, at Reese. The pill bottle rattled at the bottom of my tote bag, along with some snacks, a book, and a beach blanket. I removed my dress to reveal a bathing suit that I recently ordered. This was the first time that I had ever worn a two-piece. After a few minutes, my skin would begin a new tanning pattern that I had wished for ages, and soon I would step into the ocean for the first time as an out, trans, lesbian woman. And because I'm a glutton for ritual, I took out a pen and my
我带来了刚开好的激素药物，当下午 6 点到来时，我将服用第一剂，而我想在这里——在里斯服用它。药瓶在我的托特包底部哗啦作响，里面还有一些零食、一本书和一条沙滩巾。我脱下裙子，露出一套我最近订购的泳衣。这是我第一次穿两件套泳衣。几分钟后，我的皮肤将开始一段我渴望已久的全新美黑历程，很快我将以一个公开的跨性别女同性恋女性身份第一次走进大海。既然我对仪式感有着执念，我拿出一支笔和我的
notepad and began to write what it all meant to me. As I slowly stepped into the Atlantic, the waves lapped around my toes, and then my thighs, and finally up to my waist, same level of water as my first baptism when I was a child. Only this time, it was on my terms. I unfurled my paper and began to read. I'm here for another ritual, to leave another part of myself behind. I took the pill and just like my ancestors before me, I took a deep breath and ducked my head underwater, fully submerging myself into the sea.
记事本，开始写下这一切对我意味着什么。当我缓缓走进大西洋时，海浪拍打着我的脚趾，然后是我的大腿，最后漫到我的腰部，这水深和我小时候第一次受洗时一模一样。唯一的不同是，这一次，是由我说了算。我展开纸张开始朗读。我来这里是为了另一个仪式，为了将我的一部分留在过去。我服下药丸，就像我之前的先辈们一样，我深吸了一口气，将头潜入水下，将自己完全浸入大海中。
After the break, we leave Reis and travel west, to a different beach. And like the abandoned hospital by Reis, this beach has its own set of ruins. Stay with us. Welcome back. Here's a classic 99PI story remixed and rescored. It's about how abandoned places can have a certain kind of allure. If you've wandered at Machu Picchu or Stonehenge or the Colosseum or even snuck into that abandoned house on the edge of town, you know the power in a piece of decrepit architecture. Even if you haven't been to these places, they've been photographed and filmed for
休息过后，我们将离开里斯向西进发，去往另一片海滩。就像里斯那座废弃的医院一样，这片海滩也有它自己的一组废墟。请继续收听。欢迎回来。这是一个经过重新混音和配乐的经典 99PI 故事。它讲述了废弃的地方如何能够拥有某种特定的吸引力。如果你曾在马丘比丘、巨石阵、罗马斗兽场漫步，甚至偷偷溜进镇边缘那栋废弃的房子里，你就会明白破碎建筑所蕴含的力量。即使你没有去过这些地方，它们也已经被拍摄并记录下来供你欣赏。
you. Abandoned Soviet bus stops, deserted old movie theaters, decaying residential streets, they're fascinating in this like Planet of the Apes kind of way. So of course, there's a German word for it. Ruin and Lust, the longstanding aesthetic obsession with decay. Resident Germanophile and producer Avery Truffleman.
废弃的苏联公交车站、荒凉的老电影院、日渐衰败的住宅街道，它们以一种类似《人猿星球》的方式令人着迷。所以，当然有一个德语词汇来形容它。Ruinenlust，对衰败的长期审美迷恋。常驻德国迷兼制作人 Avery Truffleman。
It might actually be one of those made up German words. It probably is. But the concept itself is totally a real thing. Ruins inspire wonder. They give the mind this task of reconciling what's there and what's not. What once was and what now is. People flock to remainders of ancient civilizations. Romans, the Mayans, the Egyptians. But people also flock to things that just look like they're ancient too. That combination of decomposition and romance
这其实可能是那些杜撰出来的德语词汇之一。它可能确实是。但这个概念本身绝对是真实存在的。废墟激发人们的惊叹。它们给大脑留下了这样一项任务：去调和存在与不存在的东西。曾经的过往与现在的现实。人们蜂拥前往古代文明的遗迹。罗马人、玛雅人、埃及人。但人们也蜂拥前往那些看起来也很古老的事物。这种分解与浪漫的结合
makes a perfect cocktail of repulsion and allure. And for San Franciscans, this place is Sutro Baths. My friend Austin brought me there one night. So how do you get in? Does the trail just lead right to it? Yeah, yeah, there's steps. There's a parking lot up there and steps that go down. Head to the rocks at Land's End on the very northwest corner of San Francisco.
构成了排斥与吸引的完美鸡尾酒。对于旧金山人来说，这个地方就是苏特罗浴场（Sutro Baths）。我的朋友 Austin 有天晚上带我去了那里。那么怎么进去呢？小径直接通往那里吗？对，对，有台阶。上面有个停车场，有台阶通往下方的坡道。前往旧金山最西北角的兰兹角（Land's End）的岩石区。
Walk down the flight of stairs into a grassy slope that hugs the sea. Off to the right is the gaping maw of a cave. To your left is the crumbled foundation of a concrete structure. It looks like a giant Belgian waffle, about seven feet tall and 50 feet wide on the longest side. Beside the waffle are two pools of still water with a concrete jetty between them that dares you to walk its length. Make it to the end and you're at a sea wall where the Pacific Ocean crashes into the rocks.
走下一段台阶，来到一个紧贴着大海的草坡。右边是一个张开巨口的洞穴。你的左边是一个混凝土结构倒塌的地基。它看起来像一个巨大的比利时华夫饼，最长的一边大约有七英尺高、五十英尺宽。华夫饼旁边是两个静止的水池，中间有一条混凝土防波堤，挑战着你去走完它的全长。走到尽头，你就来到了太平洋拍击岩石的海堤。
There's no fence, no guards, only a warning sign that says, Danger. Cliff and surf area extremely dangerous. People have been swept from the rocks and drowned. What you can see down here are the ruins of the bathhouses. Have you heard any rumors as to what was what here? Strangely, no. And last time you were here, it was just like,
这里没有栅栏，没有警卫，只有一个警告标志，上面写着：危险。悬崖和冲浪区域极其危险。曾有人被海浪从岩石上卷走并溺水身亡。你在这里能看到的是浴场的废墟。你有没有听到过关于这里曾经是什么的任何传闻？奇怪的是，没有。你上次来这里的时候，大家是不是都在
were people wondering about the history of it at all? No, it was like 300 punks in a cave. Austin had seen a band playing in the cave. They plugged their amps into a generator that they brought themselves. He told me things like that were happening at Sutra Bats all the time. And it's easy to see why.
好奇它的历史？没有，当时就像是有 300 个朋克在山洞里。Austin 曾看到一支乐队在山洞里演出。他们把功放插到自己带来的发电机上。他告诉我，这样的事情在苏特罗浴场经常发生。原因不难理解。
This place has a draw. The night that I was there, a group of photographers was snapping shots of the moon. Is this like a known photo destination? I would say the last three years it's been more common. So I think people are finding out about it. I just know that in the like the 30s, it was some sort of bath for people to sit in
这个地方有着一种吸引力。我在那里的那天晚上，有一群摄影师正在拍摄月亮的照片。这是一个知名的摄影目的地吗？我想说过去三年里它变得更普遍了。所以我认为人们正在发现这个地方。我只知道在 20 世纪 30 年代左右，这是某种供人们坐着
and just soak. I don't know if it was hot or the 30s it was some sort of bath for people to sit in and just soak. I don't know if it was hot or cold or what it was about. Ruins have drawn people to them for centuries. Starting in the late 1600s a tradition emerged among European men of means to go visit sites of antiquity, Paris, Venice, Rome, and learn about the roots of western civilization. Today lots of people visit what's left of the old world. People like ruins. It gives us a sense of time passing, maybe a sense of place. Why do people go to ancient Egypt? Why do they go to the Acropolis? A sense of time gone by, a sense of timelessness. And I think also that urge to try to explain what people are looking at.
浸泡的浴池。我不知道它是热的还是冷的，或者这到底是怎么回事。几个世纪以来，废墟一直吸引着人们前往。从 17 世纪末开始，有钱的欧洲男性中兴起了一种传统，即去参观古代遗迹——巴黎、威尼斯、罗马，并了解西方文明的根源。今天，许多人参观旧世界的遗迹。人们喜欢废墟。它给我们一种时间流逝的感觉，或许还有一种场所感。人们为什么要去古埃及？他们为什么去卫城？一种逝去的时间感，一种永恒感。我认为还有那种试图解释人们正在看什么的冲动。
Anytime you go out to Soutre-Bez, I mean, there's people crawling all over the ruins like ants. that urge to try to explain what people are looking at. Anytime you go out to Sutro, there's people crawling all over the ruins like ants. But the thing about these ruins at the edge of the continent, they may look ancient, but they really aren't at all. You talk to them, they're all trying to figure the place out. What is this? What do these tunnels do? What's this thing?
每当你去苏特罗浴场时，我的意思是，到处都是人像蚂蚁一样爬满废墟。试图解释人们正在看什么的冲动。每当你去苏特罗时，到处都是人像蚂蚁一样爬满废墟。但关于大陆边缘的这些废墟，它们看起来可能很古老，但实际上一点也不古老。你跟他们交流，他们都在试图弄清楚这个地方。这是什么？这些隧道是做什么用的？这是什么东西？
There's a curiosity to it. They know they're ruins, and if they know the name Sutro Bathro, they know they were swimming pools. And that's about it. This is historian John Martini. Martini wrote a book about this place called Sutro's Glass Palace. So named because this pool of water used to be underneath an enormous glass structure. And it was the pet project of Adolf Sutro. The name Sutro might sound familiar to you, especially if you live in San Francisco. There's Sutro Tower, Sutro Heights, there's a Sutro library at the San Francisco State University, all named after this one German immigrant. He struck it rich by
这带有一种好奇心。他们知道它们是废墟，如果他们知道“苏特罗浴场”这个名字，他们就知道这里曾是游泳池。仅此而已。这是历史学家 John Martini。Martini 写了一本关于这个地方的书，名叫《苏特罗的玻璃宫殿》（Sutro's Glass Palace）。之所以这么叫，是因为这个水池过去位于一座巨大的玻璃结构下方。这是阿道夫·苏特罗（Adolf Sutro）的心血结晶。“苏特罗”这个名字你可能听起来很耳熟，特别是如果你住在旧金山的话。有苏特罗塔、苏特罗高地，旧金山州立大学还有一个苏特罗图书馆，都是以这位德国移民的名字命名的。他在 18 世纪 60 年代的内华达州白银淘金热期间，通过
engineering a mining tunnel during the Nevada Silver Strike in the 1860s, and he turned his money into San Francisco real estate. A lot of real estate. Some historians estimate that at one point, Adolf Sutro owned one-twelfth of the city. Adolf Sutro was to San Francisco what John D. Rockefeller was to New York and what Henry Huntington was to LA. Sutro built public gardens, presented free concerts, and built the structure that would eventually become Sutro Baths. Sutro's original idea was that he wanted to build a giant outdoor aquarium that would be filled by the tides and it would empty at low tide.
设计一条矿业隧道而发了一笔横财，并把他的资金转化为旧金山的房地产。大量的房地产。一些历史学家估计，在某个时期，阿道夫·苏特罗拥有了这座城市十二分之一的土地。阿道夫·苏特罗对于旧金山，就如同约翰·D·洛克菲勒对于纽约，以及亨利·亨廷顿对于洛杉矶。苏特罗建造了公共花园，举办免费音乐会，并建造了最终成为苏特罗浴场的建筑。苏特罗最初的想法是，他想建造一个巨大的室外水族馆，由潮汐注水，并在退潮时排空。
So in 1884, he created a catch basin that refilled naturally as the waves broke in. And then Sutro kept making more and more plans, adding on and on to his aquarium. He built the network of swimming pools, connecting canals, he even built a powerhouse as a freestanding building to heat the water. Then when all that was done, then he hires an architectural firm. Assembly would be like if some crazy self-improvement guy built the foundation for an elaborate house, but didn't know what the house was going to look like. He just built the foundation, and he plumbed it. And then you hire an architect to come in and make a building fit on top of what was
所以在 1884 年，他建造了一个集水盆地，当海浪拍打进来时，它会自动重新注水。然后苏特罗不断制定越来越多的计划，不断为他的水族馆添砖加瓦。他建造了游泳池网、连接运河，甚至还建造了一座独立的发电设备建筑来给水加热。然后，当这一切都完成后，他才雇佣了一家建筑事务所。这组装过程就像是一个疯狂的自我完善狂为一栋精致的房子打好了地基，却不知道房子最终会长什么样。他只是建造了地基，并铺设了管道。然后你雇佣一个建筑师来设计一栋建筑，让它契合在
already there. That's how the baths were designed. From the outside, Sutro Baths looked like an ornate palatial greenhouse. Underneath its majestic three-tiered glass canopy were several different swimming pools, hot water and cold, salt water and fresh, and there were more than 500 individual changing rooms beneath the sweeping arena style bleachers. And attached to the baths was a museum full of Sutro's crazy collection of stuff from around the world. Miniature boats, model buildings, taxidermied animals,
已经存在的东西之上。这就是浴场的设计方式。从外面看，苏特罗浴场看起来像一个华丽宏伟的宫殿式温室。在其雄伟的三层玻璃穹顶下，有几个不同的游泳池，有热水和冷水，海水和淡水，在层叠的竞技场式看台下方有 500 多个独立更衣室。浴场还连着一个博物馆，里面摆满了苏特罗从世界各地收集的疯狂藏品。微型船只、建筑模型、动物标本、
gems, mechanical figures, a real Egyptian mummy, all inside of a glass palace facing the ocean at the edge of San Francisco. Up the hill, towards the road, was a street called Mary Way. There was a Firth Wheel, basically a Ferris wheel, along with a roller coaster and a hall of mirrors and games of chance. And keep in mind Sutro was building at the edge of nowhere on the rocks by the sea. And public transit didn't go there.
宝石、机械玩偶、一具真正的埃及木乃伊，全都位于旧金山边缘面对着大西洋的玻璃宫殿内。顺着山坡往上走，朝向公路的方向，有一条叫玛丽威（Mary Way）的街道。那里有一个费尔斯轮，基本上就是一个摩天轮，还有一个过山车、一个镜迷宫和各种运气游戏。记住，苏特罗当时是在海边岩石上、荒凉的边缘地带进行建造的。而且当时公共交通并不通达这里。
And this was a challenge for both construction workers and for customers. It lost money from the day it opened. It was a huge white elephant. It cost Adolf Sutro about a million dollars when it opened in 1894. And you put that today, that statement, 37, $40 million. It couldn't make money from the charging people
这对建筑工人和顾客来说都是一个挑战。它从开业的第一天起就在赔钱。这是一个巨大的累赘。1894 年开业时，它花费了阿道夫·苏特罗大约一百万美元。如果你把这个数字换算到今天，大概是 3700 万到 4000 万美元。它根本无法通过向人们收取
10 cents to get in and 15 cents to go swimming. It would have had to be packed almost every day. And in an attempt to pack the house, Sutro poured even more money into electric rail lines to be packed almost every day. And in an attempt to pack the house, Sutro poured even more money into electric rail lines that led out to the baths. This was a huge boon for the city's mass transit. At the same time, remember, he owned all the land
10 美分门票和 15 美分游泳费来盈利。它几乎每天都得挤满人才行。为了让这里爆满，苏特罗投入了更多的资金来修建通往浴场的高铁线路。这对于该市的公共交通来说是一个巨大的福音。与此同时，别忘了，他拥有人们将会穿行其周围的所有土地，而且总是有关于苏特罗土地公司（Sutro Land Company）的广告，试图出售土地。所以他既在为公众做事，同时又在试图赚钱。但苏特罗浴场就是从来、从来没有赚过钱。到阿道夫·苏特罗于 1894 年当选市长时，他心爱的浴场仍然没有实现盈利。
surrounding it that people were gonna be traveling through, and there were always advertisements for the Sutro Land Company where they're trying to sell land. So he's doing things for the public at the same time trying to make some money. But Sutro Baths just never, ever made money. By the time Adolf Sutro was elected mayor in 1894, his beloved baths were still not turning a profit.
四年后的 1898 年他去世时，他的家人开始寻找机会脱手这处房产。苏特罗家族多年来一直试图出售苏特罗浴场，同时也一直在勇敢地努力让它实现盈利。1934 年，我父亲被先驱阿道夫·苏特罗的孙子阿道夫·苏特罗雇用了。就在那个时候，阿道夫·苏特罗想要做点什么来吸引更多人来到这里。如果你去苏特罗浴场，你可能会遇到汤姆·布拉顿（Tom Bratton）。我叫汤姆·布拉顿，现在我为国家公园做志愿者，每周来这里一次，待上几个小时，跟人们交谈，让他们确切了解所有这些
When he died four years later in 1898, his family started looking to get rid of the property. The Sutro family tried for years to sell Sutro Baths, while also trying valiantly to make it turn a profit. In 1934, my father was hired by Adolf Sutro, who is the grandson of the pioneer Adolf Sutro. Just about that time, Adolf Sutro wanted to do something to get more people out here. If you go to Sutro Baths, you may run into Tom Bratton. My name is Tom Bratton and now I volunteer for the National Parks and come out here once a week and for a few hours and talk to people and let them know just exactly what all these
废墟的由来。汤姆的父亲是一名工程师，他曾协助苏特罗浴场经历了它那非常古怪的中年危机。他们把底部的游泳池切断，将其与常规泳池隔开，把水排干，在上面撒上沙子，放了一些桌子、乒乓球桌和野餐桌，他们把这叫做“热带海滩”。热带海滩本应是一个室内温暖的沙质休闲场所，尽管真正的海滩就在外面。这个方案效果并不是很好。
ruins were about. Tom's father was an engineer and he helped Sucho Baths undergo its really wiggy midlife crisis. They cut off the bottom pool, cut that off from the regular pool, drained it, scattered sand around on it, put in some tables, ping pong tables and picnic tables, and they called that the Tropic Beach. The Tropic Beach was supposed to be a warm, sandy place indoors just to hang out, even though the real beach was right outside. That really didn't work out too well.
这真的很遗憾，因为海滩外面冰冷刺骨，而且通常雾气蒙蒙。一个热带版本其实并不过分。所以他们说，好吧，那这样呢？我们把那个热带海滩拆掉，在那里搭建一个平台，把它改造成一个溜冰场。”当汤姆读高中时，他的父亲给他找了一份在这家溜冰场工作的工作。是的，汤姆曾在建筑仍然屹立不倒时在这里工作，考虑到废墟看起来如此古老，这似乎是不可能的。人们真的会走过来对我说，这些真的是来自罗马的废墟吗？
Which really is a shame because right outside the beach is freezing and usually foggy. A tropical version isn't that crazy. And so they said, well, how about this? We'll take that Tropic Beach away and we'll put a platform there and we'll make that into an ice rink." And when Tom was in high school, his father got him a job working at this very ice rink. Yes, Tom worked at this place while it was still standing, which seems impossible given how ancient the ruins look. People will really come up to me and say, were these really ruins from Rome?
而我会说，其实不是，只是苏特罗浴场而已。到汤姆在那里工作时，这个地方的名字已经从苏特罗浴场改为了简称为“苏特罗”。苏特罗家族最终在 1952 年将这个地方出手，当时娱乐大亨乔治·惠特尼（George Whitney）买下了它。当汤姆·布拉顿开始担任更衣室服务员时，惠特尼就是老板。而且比苏特罗家族更甚，乔治·惠特尼真的在竭尽全力让人们来到这里。
And I say, not really, just Sutro baths. By the time Tom was employed there, the name of the place had changed from Sutro baths to just Sutros. The Sutro family had finally gotten rid of this place in 1952 when entertainment tycoon George Whitney bought it. Whitney was the boss when Tom Bratton started as a locker attendant. And even more than the Sutro family, George Whitney was really trying to do everything he could to get people to come out.
所以他增添了更多的游乐设施，包括一项高高凌驾于海面上空、在苏特罗两侧悬崖之间穿梭的游乐设施。他称之为“空中缆车”（Sky Tram）。空中缆车，这个东西大约能容纳 20 人。过河大约需要 20 分钟。所以他们并没有赚到多少钱。惠特尼还认为鸟舍可能会带来大笔收入，
So he tacked on more amusements, including a ride high above the sea that shuttled between the two cliffs on either side of Sutro's. He called it the Sky Tram. The Sky Tram, this thing would hold about 20 people. It took about 20 minutes to get across. So they didn't make a lot of money on it. Whitney also thought an aviary might bring in the big money,
于是他订购了一些珍奇鸟类和一些笼子。结果是所有的鸟都在笼子到达之前一股脑全送到了。于是惠特尼叫来所有员工说：“好了，这里的每个人都带一只鸟回家，等我们的笼子到了，我们再把鸟带回来。”真是个烂摊子。但即使在有了溜冰场、鸟舍和空中缆车之后，人们依然没有来苏特罗。
so he ordered some exotic birds and some cages. What happened was all the birds came in at once before the cages. So they had Whitney called all the employees and says, okay, everybody here take home a bird until our cages come in and then we'll bring the birds back. What a mess. But even after the ice rink and the aviary and the SkyTram, people still weren't coming to Sutro's.
在苦苦挣扎了 14 年后，惠特尼家族决定出售这处房产。历史学家 John Martini 再次登场。它被卖给了一个房地产开发商，后者开始对其进行拆除。1966 年 6 月，正是在那个时候，一场“恰逢其时”的大火爆发了。1966 年，一场神秘的大火爆发，将苏特罗变成了一堆瓦砾。人们怀疑是纵火犯所为，但无人被捕。随后苏特罗就再也没有被重建。最终，最后一位业主于 1980 年将土地卖给了国家公园管理局。所以它是大型国家公园区域的一部分。
The Whitney's, after struggling for 14 years, decided they were going to sell the property. Historian John Martini, again. It was sold to a land developer who began to demolish it. And in June 66, that's when the very convenient fire broke out. In 1966, a mysterious fire broke out and reduced Sutros to a pile of rubble. An arsonist was suspected, but no one was arrested. And then Sutro's was just never rebuilt. Eventually the last owner sold the land to the National Park Service in 1980. So it's part of a big national park area.
苏特罗浴场就位于金门国家休养地（Golden Gate National Recreation Area）内，当政府最终买下它时，它被无缝地纳入了这个大型国家公园区域中。它本身不是国家公园，而且看起来一点也不像属于金门国家公园保护区（Golden Gate National Park's conservancy）的一部分。它看起来只是一堆废墟。有时，废墟比修缮后的遗址更具感染力，因为人们更有一种这是真品的真实感。尽管这些废墟只有 45 年的历史，但它们有着同样的吸引力。那种试图解释人们正在看什么的冲动。所以与其他废墟不同，苏特罗浴场的遗迹历史不到 50 年。
Sutro Baths is right inside Golden Gate National Recreation Area, and when the government finally bought it, it was seamlessly included into this big national park area. It's not a national park itself, and it doesn't look like it belongs within the Golden Gate National Park's conservancy at all. It just looks like a bunch of ruins. Sometimes ruins are more evocative than if the site is restored, because there's more sense that this is the real deal. Even though these are only 45 years old, they have the same attraction. That urge to try to explain what people are looking at. So unlike other ruins, remains of Sutro Baths were less than 50 years old.
它们是国家公园的一部分。自 2012 年以来，它们在现场确实拥有自己的小型博物馆和礼品店，就沿着曾经是中途岛的玛丽威旁。路标依然存在。然而，这些废墟仍然相当危险，对许多人来说，依然充满神秘。所以此时，你可能想知道如何前往浴场，或者关于停车位的可用性，或者也许你是否可以在那里举办你的摄影活动。Jill 可以帮忙。人们写信问我：我可以在那里举办婚礼吗？我怎么去那里？我可以在那里拍电影吗？
They are part of a national park. Since 2012, they do have their own tiny museum and gift shop on site, right along Mary Way, where the Midway used to be. The street sign is still there. And yet the ruins are still pretty dangerous and to many people, still mysterious. So at this point, you may be wondering how to get out to the baths or about parking availability or maybe if you can go hold your photo shoot there. Jill can help. People write to me with, can I have my wedding there? How can I get there? Can I film my movie there?
我回答他们所有的问题。Jill Corral 经营着 sutrobaths.com。我不会说：哦，我只是西雅图的一个普通女孩。来自西雅图。你知道的，我只是回复他们的问题。比如：是的，你的婚礼派对少于 30 人吗？当然，你可以在那里举办。
I answer all their questions. Jill Corral runs sutrobaths.com. And I don't say like, oh, I'm just this random chick in Seattle. From Seattle. You know, I just respond to their question. Like, yes, is your wedding party smaller than 30 people? Sure, you can have it there.
Jill 在 2000 年抢注了 sutrobaths.com。我简直不敢相信这个域名当时还是可用的。如果你在 Facebook 或 Twitter 上联系苏特罗浴场，这些账号也是由身在西雅图的 Jill 运营的。我很喜欢人们问我这样的问题：要花多少钱？我能进去吗？感觉就像是：去就是了。它永远不会关闭。
Jill snagged sutrobaths.com in 2000. I couldn't believe that the domain was available. If you contact Sutro Baths on Facebook or Twitter, those accounts are also run by Jill in Seattle. I love it when people ask me, like, how much does it cost? Can I get in? It's just like, just go. It's never closed.
吉尔在2000年抢注了sutrobaths.com。我简直不敢相信这个域名居然没被注册。如果你在Facebook或Twitter上联系苏特罗浴场，这些账号其实也是西雅图的吉尔在运营。我特别喜欢别人问我，比如，这要花多少钱？我能进去吗？感觉就像是，直接去就行了。它永远不会关门。
And unlike Tom Bratton or John Martini, who actually both experienced Sutro Baths when it was a functioning building, Jill first encountered the place as a ruin. I was flown out to San Francisco for a job interview in 1997. My main mission was to touch the Pacific Ocean that day before my interview. I went down there and I stumbled on this just insane playground of concrete and metal sticking out of the ground. I didn't know what the hell it was. It was just pretty much the closest to a magical place I'd found as an adult. And I fell in love. I think I will toss my ashes there after I die. Well, I won't, someone else will. Jill actually did bury her two pet lizards there.
与实际上都曾经历过苏特罗浴场营业时期的汤姆·布拉顿或约翰·马蒂尼不同，吉尔最初是在一片废墟中遇到这个地方的。“1997年，我飞到旧金山参加工作面试。我的主要任务就是在面试前的那天去摸一下太平洋。我走到那里，无意中发现了这个由混凝土和金属组成的、从地面突出来的疯狂游乐场。我当时根本不知道这到底是什么鬼东西。作为成年人，它几乎是我找到的最接近神奇地方的存在。我坠入爱河了。我想我死后要把骨灰撒在那里。好吧，我自己不会，别人会去撒。”吉尔实际上把她的两只宠物蜥蜴埋在了那里。
They're in the cave. The story of Sutro Baths didn't exactly shape history. Yes, it helped expand San Francisco public transit. Yes, you can see the ruins briefly in a scene in the movie Harold and Maude, but ultimately it was a strange glass complex at the edge of the ocean that was destined to fail. And amusements and attractions were constantly added
它们在洞穴里。苏特罗浴场的历史并没有真正改变历史的走向。是的，它有助于扩展旧金山的公共交通；是的，你可以在电影《哈罗德和莫德》的一个场景中短暂地看到这些废墟；但归根结底，它只是海边一个注定要失败的奇怪玻璃综合体。而且娱乐和景点在它的生命周期中不断被添加
and removed throughout its life. But in a city as rapidly gentrifying as San Francisco, in a country as young as the United States, these ruins are an anomaly. I respect people's desire for it to be like this mysterious unknown thing, as young as the United States. These ruins are an anomaly. beautiful magical thing here, like you have to know about it. Always read the plaque, right? You got it. In addition to researching what the baths were, Jill keeps tabs on how they're changing.
并在其存在期间不断被移除。但在一个像旧金山这样快速绅士化的城市，在一个像美国这样年轻的国家，这些废墟是一个特例。我尊重人们希望它成为这样一个神秘未知事物的愿望，就像年轻的美国一样。这些废墟是一个特例。这里有美丽神奇的事物，就像你必须了解它一样。总得读读牌匾对吧？你懂的。除了研究浴场曾经是什么样的，吉尔还一直在关注它们是如何变化的。
Ruins seem static, like a fixed ending, but of course they're not. I have watched it continue to fall apart. There used to be a deck that you could go and read on by the cave, and then it just crumbled into the sea sometime around 2005. It's still living and dying in slow-mo.
废墟似乎是静止的，就像一个固定的结局，但它们当然不是。我看着它继续分崩离析。曾经有一个甲板，你可以在洞穴旁边去那里阅读，然后它在2005年前后就崩塌坠入大海了。它仍然在以慢动作经历着生老病死。
Which is a process the parks are actually trying to stop, according to Tom Bratton. As far as the national parks go, they wanna make it so that it's not gonna deteriorate any more than it already has. If it deteriorates any more, you're not going to really be able to tell what it really was. Tom speculates they might do this by adding more signs, maybe stabilizing some of the decaying structures, but not too much more.
根据汤姆·布拉顿的说法，这也是公园方面实际上正试图阻止的过程。就国家公园而言，他们希望确保它不会比现在恶化得更厉害。如果它进一步恶化，你就真的无法看出它原本是什么样子了。汤姆推测，他们可能会通过增加更多标牌来做到这一点，也许会加固一些正在腐朽的结构，但不会再做更多了。
Well, what the parks really don't want to do, they don't want to make it look like a box to go inside and look at the ruins and then come out again. But recently, the young ruins have become something else entirely. Nature's reclaiming the site. The ruins continue to evolve. The old swimming pools themselves have become partly silted in. It's become a wetland. Migrating birds love the site. And recently an otter appeared swimming in Sutro Baths.
嗯，公园真正不想做的是，他们不想让它看起来像一个盒子，让人走进去看看废墟然后再走出来。但最近，年轻的废墟已经完全变成了另一种东西。大自然正在重新占领这个遗址。废墟仍在继续演变。旧的游泳池本身已经部分淤积。它变成了一片湿地。候鸟非常喜欢这个地方。最近，人们还发现了一只水獭在苏特罗浴场里游泳。
The public dubbed him Sutro Sam. an otter appeared swimming in Sutro Baths. The public dubbed him Sutro Sam. Sutro Baths continues to be a machine for generating new San Francisco folklore. Today, Sutro Baths is pretty much back to where it started. All that remains is the foundation, including the original catch basin that Adolf Sutro built before ever imagining a swimming pool,
公众给它起名叫萨特罗·萨姆。一只水獭出现在苏特罗浴场里游泳。公众给它起名叫萨特罗·萨姆。苏特罗浴场继续成为产生新的旧金山民间传说的机器。今天，苏特罗浴场基本上回到了它最初的起点。剩下的只有地基，包括阿道夫·萨特罗在从未想象过要建造一个游泳池之前就建造的原始集水盆，
a tropic beach, a carnival midway, an ice skating rink. So after all the years of building this palace of wonder after adding games and rides and oddities, trying and failing to draw the public out to this strange place by the ocean, all Adolf Sutro or George Whitney had to do was let it burn down and crumble into ruin. That story was produced by Avery Jasmine JT Green and edited by Lasha Madon, mixed by Martin Gonzalez and music by me, Swan Royale. Cathy Tu is our executive producer, Kurt Kolstedt is our digital director, Delaney Hall is our senior editor, Taylor Shedstad is our digital director. Delaney Hall is our senior editor. Taylor
一个热带海滩、一个狂欢节露天游乐场、一个溜冰场。所以在经历了多年建造这座奇迹宫殿、添加游戏游乐设施和奇观、尝试却未能吸引公众来到海边这个奇怪的地方之后，阿道夫·萨特罗或乔治·惠特尼所需要做的，只是任由它被大火烧毁并坍塌成废墟。该节目由Avery Jasmine、JT Green制作，Lasha Madon剪辑，Martin Gonzalez混音，音乐由我Swan Royale创作。Cathy Tu是我们的执行制片人，Kurt Kolstedt是我们的数字总监，Delaney Hall是我们的高级编辑，Taylor Shedstad是我们的数字总监。Delaney Hall是我们的高级编辑。Taylor
Shedrick is our intern. The rest of the team includes Chris Berube, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Lay, Joe Rosenberg, Gabriella Gladney, Kelly Prime, Jacob Maldonado-Medina, Nina Potuck, and of course, Roman Mars. The 99% Invisible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Stitcher and SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building, in beautiful uptown Oakland, California. You can find us on all the usual social media sites, as well as on our new Discord server. There's a link to that, as well as every past 99PI episode at 99PI.org. The End. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
谢德里克是我们的实习生。团队的其他成员包括Chris Berube、Jason DeLeon、Emmett Fitzgerald、Christopher Johnson、Vivian Lay、Joe Rosenberg、Gabriella Gladney、Kelly Prime、Jacob Maldonado-Medina、Nina Potuck，当然还有Roman Mars。99% Invisible标志由Stefan Lawrence设计。我们是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客家族的一部分，现在总部位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的住宅区北部六个街区的潘多拉大楼。你可以在所有常规社交媒体网站以及我们的新Discord服务器上找到我们。那里有一个链接，以及99PI的每一期过往节目，网址是99PI.org。结束。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。